good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a Thursday that
feels like a Wednesday here in New York
City hey Claude hid hey guys how you
doing hey Jax how you doing I'm feeling
good you know
what a busy week actually this week
really flew by I had like something to
do every day which is V rare be special
be unique and it really makes time fly
by when you have things to do like I
look for things to do today you know
what I'm doing later today I am
recording Jenna Ushkowitz and Kevin
McHale they have a Glee recap podcast so
they gave me an episode to watch and
we're gonna recap it and I'm like so
excited I literally couldn't sleep last
night that's so exciting for you I think
that's exactly where you're meant to be
and what you're supposed to be doing I
get this point in your life and so I
hope that it's fabulous no way I have a
feeling it's gonna be quite fabulous me
and Jenna have been texting yeah that's
right I'm the new member of New
Directions um that's as fabulous as well
Tina Tina cohen-chang
those last few seasons were not kind to
Tina well actually I think the first few
seasons were not kind to Tina
they made her character fake having a
speech impediment and like fake being
Goss and then it turns out like she was
really just like not goth and like not
had a speech impediment and they kind of
glazed over her introduction to the
series as being like kind of [ __ ] up
ya know there were some things that
could have been addressed differently on
the show but you know there were so many
different characters and there's only so
much time in primetime
I mean can you imagine that outrage now
if a student that was supposed to be a
handicapped was cast as a non
handicapped person like Artie Kevin
McHale yeah he's not in a wheelchair
yeah
very chair he actually spoke about that
on our show he was like I know like I
can't even talk like I'm sure he gets
that all the time yeah it's just
different for times you know it wasn't
that long ago anyways
it's kind of gloomy here in New York
which I'm so here for because the nice
weather just makes me sad that I'm not
outside but when it's gloomy I'm like
well I would be inside anyway so yeah
that's your room I'm feeling good about
the day ready to take it on I am going
today to get um an antibody test so um
I'm nervous I don't like getting blood
taken yeah they do take a substantial
amount of blood like it's not like a
finger prick it's a vial and it file and
I feel as though you're gonna freak out
yes I do have a flair for the dramatics
you have a flair for the dramatics but
it's really not a big thing it's pretty
quick what can I say it's my love of the
theater I'm a thespian at heart you're
just performing everywhere that you go
wait we have a really exciting update
today I don't wanna o'clock Eastern Time
so probably a mere 30 minutes after
you're listening to this episode if you
listen when it drops we are launching
TNT masks on shop TMT comm shop morning
toast calm and they're so sweet they're
so sweet there's four different options
some toasty ones some Thai Thai it's
fabulous so make sure to go to shop
morning toast comm there is unlimited
stock so no one is gonna be able to miss
out you have until Sunday to place your
orders so take your time get send it to
your friends you have four days nowhere
no rush no stock you can get as many as
you want
shop morning toast calm and thanks for
days there's four different mask styles
they're all so cute and we made some of
them so that they would match your
existing merch that way like your
sweatshirt and the mask that you get
will already match and I'm just so
excited we've been working really hard
on these and we're excited that you are
gonna get to order them so pre-orders
start today 1 o'clock p.m. Eastern Time
go until Sunday night get your masks get
your masks but first listen to this
episode we have a fabulous episode
planned for you before we dive in you
know we gotta set herself up for success
today's word of the day Jackie you
courtesy of Miss merriam-webster is it's
a nod to one of my favorite shows
younger the word is empirical
oh wow originating in had it were felled
how okay
it means originating in or based on
observation or experience relying on
experience or observation alone often
without due regard for system and theory
by the way I am so empirical that's not
a good thing it sounds like well no it
just means like I say things be based on
my experience not based on whether or
not they're fact which is like literally
me yeah maybe your viewpoint can be
viewed as empirical at times and you
know what I'm totally okay with that
empirical I get that it's kind of a
negative word but it sounds [ __ ]
fabulous and royal it does sound
fabulous so hopefully when you say like
oh I'm so empirical in my thinking
people will just assume it's a fabulous
positive thing yeah I'll just assume
that they don't know the word of the day
no they definitely don't know the word
unless they're toaster in which case we
love them yeah I know the word of the
day we're also getting our toaster yeah
I got that and we're also gonna recap
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills which
was I liked it I thought it was um a
good non important episode like not
every episode is gonna be there you know
season finale and I actually thought
there was a lot going on in this episode
I love Santa Barbara and I just want to
go there one day it reminds me a
politician and I just think it's
fabulous
I knew you were gonna be focused on the
Santa Barbara at all like the house is
so stunning I love that they went there
that little Wharf that they went to was
so cute and they were just like walking
and taking bikes and that was a strange
turn of events for the Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills but um I really liked
the the setting I really did yeah I have
a lot of thoughts so we'll dive in after
the fast five so what's up further ado
Jackie take it away let's get into the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast first story the
big story of the day
very sad devastating news Scott Disick
and Sophia Ricci break up after nearly
three years together it is over for
Scott and Sophia a source confirms to
page six that the stars have broken up
saying the relation
ran its course but that other issues
including Disick's past traumas that led
him to rehab contributed to the split
quote scott had gotten back into his old
ways and Sophia got fed up they had been
quarantining separately which also took
a bit of a toll on their romance the
source added that Disick's relationship
with ex Kourtney the mother of his
children wait on Ricci quote Kourtney
didn't make it easy for her the source
cleaned and you can only tolerate that
kind of treatment for so long I feel
like that laughs nobody's um a little
bit not true yeah there's so many
different layers to this I feel like at
no point was ever really Kourtney like a
factor in Scott and um Sophia's
relationship like obviously they
co-parent but beyond that I don't really
see see that second half of the story I
agree I'm like sad about this obviously
cuz I like them together but I just like
Sofia being a part of the Kardashian
crew like that's the personally like the
loss um taking on the most um but I just
really like I know a lot of people shape
them I just like don't mean this this I
just hope this doesn't mean he's getting
back together with Kourtney no I don't
think so either and I feel like
definitely maybe Kourtney was um in
obstacle in the relationship in the
beginning but three years later she's
been on the show like she's with the
kids she's best friends with Kylie I
feel like they have figured out how to
be a blended family so I don't think
that that was the issue anymore but
maybe Scott is going through stuff I
just I love these two like I'm gonna
hold out hope that they get back
together but I don't want to waste my
time you know I'm maybe I just need to
like move on bills new ship like it's
gonna take me I thought I could break it
up before right I don't why does this
one feel so final like I feel like Nate
because it was widely reported like
Jenna was emailing everyone yeah usually
when they've broken up it's been kind of
speculative and not in every single
publication but this is like reported as
fact and I'm just assuming that it is
true he just celebrated his birthday we
didn't see her there I'm gonna take this
one on its face and say that it's it's
the truth it's the curse of quarantine
it has there's something in the air yeah
there is something in the air either
breaking up or getting pregnant
so let's play a little game who are we
shipping these two with like when life
goes back to normal like I really want
Sophia to stay and like in the Calabasas
either community ecosystem like who
could we set her up with like French
Montana like who still hangs with me
Sophia and Rob I just don't think it's
gonna work for me I mean I'll just
anything to be sister of Kylie first
Sophia but then like if she gets with
with Rob like hypothetically like she
really couldn't ever get back with Scott
like we need like a Kardashian outsider
to like hold on to her until Scott like
works through his traumas and is ready
to take on the relationship again hmm I
mean maybe she could just do her own
thing for a while I hope her and Kylie
will still be friends Miche like you
would think with the Kardashians that
there's so many politics and like
certain people would like you would
honestly think at the beginning that
none of them would have been friends
with Sophia because she's like Scott's
new girl but they always like they
always just when you think one thing
about them they always flip it on its
head and it's like they really embraced
Sophia so and even like with French
Montana like he always sticks around and
even though Hema Khloe dated very
briefly a million years ago he's invited
to Christmas every year he's just one of
those people who I think like five with
them so they're always surprising me I
don't know I hope that Sophia sticks
around I like her but um I was reading
some blinds that um Sophia's family
didn't like Scott but we hadn't known
that to be true because Lionel said some
stuff but I would have thought after
three years and like they seemed so good
together at a certain point it's like
the proof is in the pudding yeah it's a
good it's a good thing a pudding
just right so and also that seems like
that was something that was always there
just like Kourtney so why now why three
years later when we're when it seems
like we're all in a great place are we
gonna give up on this well it definitely
has a lot to do with what Scott's going
through because we know he just went
through this um
trip to rehab so the timing makes sense
in the sense that he might not be able
to give himself to a relationship he's
really dealing with a lot so yeah I hope
that that's not the case but I think
that it is and that makes me really sad
because Scott's a good person and he
lost both of his parents at the same
time and it was just so sad he doesn't
have any family and I don't know I feel
like I feel like he needs a hug
like he needs it from Courtney and she's
like not giving it to him like a
friendly hug yeah but he gets them from
like Khloe and Kim and I think you pay
really close yeah I love watching their
friendship um he definitely has a lot to
work through and I'm glad that he's now
taking the time to do those things I
just hope that he'll find love again
soon in a hopeless place yes Oh Bravo oh
no someone tweeted like when you would
think of Rihanna's lyrics we found love
in a hopeless place what place do you
automatically think of I saw Bravo's
response and it was epic I personally I
think of the jug at Kohli cuz that song
used to always play there and then like
if you met someone at the jug it was
like kind of like grungy and like you
could find love in a hopeless place yeah
I also think of it as just like a dirty
Club yeah I think you're meant to but
Bravo responded the Regency which is
[ __ ] hilarious whoever runs the Bravo
watch happens live um social media
literally should be a case study for all
brands like their tick-tock is so good
they have made so many sounds on
tick-tock go viral like exactly like
they just do such a good job on their
social media like especially the watch
happens live accounts whoever does is
doing that's a service raise I hope they
get it video ok next story is all social
media are notoriously underpaid that's
true next story is also a big story of
the day today youtuber Mika Stauffer
reveals she quote rehomed her son who
has autism two years after she adopted
him youtuber Mika Stoffer and her
husband James have announced they've
decided to quote this is their word
rehome their son Huxley who they adopted
nearly three years ago from China Mika
and James said that they weren't aware
of what it would be like to take care of
Huxley who has autism quote once Huxley
came home there was a lot more special
needs that we weren't aware of and that
we were not told James said in a video
shared on Tuesday quote for us it's been
really hard hearing from the medical
professionals a lot of their feedback
and things that have been been upsetting
he continued we've never wanted to be
this position and we're trying to get
his needs met and help him out as much
as possible we truly love him the wife
added that there's not an ounce of our
body that doesn't love Huxley with all
of our being there wasn't a minute that
I didn't try our hardest and I think
what Jim is trying to say is that after
multiple assessments after multiple
evaluations numerous medical
professionals have felt that he needed a
different fit and that his medical needs
he needed more do I feel like a failure
as a mom like five hundred percent
she said that Huxley was living with a
new mommy in a forever home okay and I
read from a reporter on Twitter
confirming that he's in a foster home so
that is not a forever home and this
story is very very very disturbing on so
many levels
um because first of all they crowdfunded
from their followers raising money to
help them adopt like I guess I don't
know what the costs are but adopting a
child from another country is very
expensive I've heard so they
crowd-sourced the money um they were
actually at one point talking about
adopting another child and then they
just went silent they deleted every
comment people asking like where's
Huxley where's that's like and now this
video comes down and it's just really
disturbing um to think about on so many
levels because you have to imagine if
you know one of their biological
children was diagnosed with special
needs or you know was growing up with
different behavioral issues
would they have rehomed their biological
child I don't know them but I'm gonna go
ahead and say no right and once you
adopt a child like into your house like
they are your child so this is such a
disturbing story and like at first I'm
like you know what this is weird but as
long as the kid is happy and in a good
place like that's all that matters but
now knowing the kid might spend like a
lot of time in the foster care system I
just have a pit like this is a [ __ ]
terrible story this is a [ __ ]
terrible story there's just no way
around it like who does this I don't
know I've been following it since
yesterday morning and I wanted to talk
about it yesterday um on the toast but
there were no like news articles written
about it it was just like blogger drama
so we waited till today and I'm glad
because more information came out about
it I'm just I'm so curious as to like
who are these people
I don't know I I've never heard of her
as a blogger before but she has like 160
k um but leave a lot on YouTube her
husband you tube and they have four
other children yeah and I don't know I'm
I just don't even know what the right
thing is to say because of like you know
raising a child with special needs is
difficult and I have so much respect for
people who do but it's like you don't
just give up like you don't just give up
no it's I don't need it's such a weird
story like I never thought I would be
like speak about this ya know it's such
a weird story it gives me such a pit and
to hear that she what she said was
untrue that he's not in a new home the
child and that he's in a foster home no
he's in a new home he's not enough
forever home because it's not the whole
concept of foster homes is that they're
temporary right yeah and no but that
he's not in a forever home ya know it
just gives me a bit like cuz at first it
was like alright you are weird but at
least the kid is being taken care of but
now I just feel like his whole futures
up in the air in a country he wasn't
born in like he this is all so new to
him and I don't know I just I feel like
more could have been done on behalf of
these bloggers yeah I agree
this is terrible terrible the comments
have just been like people are people
are mad well at first she was being like
um
police woman commenter like I saw only
positive comments and I'm like how can
you even say something positive about
this like because whether or not you
agree with what they did like it's still
a terrible situation whatever angle you
look at it from so I guess now because
there's been so much press are such an
overwhelming amount of comments that
they can't police them but at first I
was seeing
90% overwhelming majority like positive
like mommy comments like you did by
Judge Joe you're not a bad mom geez
that's crazy this is gonna be like a
Netflix documentary in like a year I
could just feel it I know I feel like
everything that happens now everyone's
just like sniffing
around like would this be good for a
miniseries Netflix no totally like yeah
exactly yeah um okay well some some
happy motherly news Sasha Pieterse from
Pretty Little Liars is pregnant she's
expecting her first child with Hudson
Schaeffer Sasha Pieterse has a baby on
the way on Wednesday the Pretty Little
Liars alum announced she's pregnant and
expecting her first child with husband
Hudson she for two years after they tied
the knot quote we are so beyond excited
to finally share our sweet news with all
of you we will be welcoming a precious
little human this October Peter shared
on Instagram posting a photo of Schaffer
kissing her growing baby bump
that is so cute those pretty little
liars girls are just like all thriving
in their own respective ways mm-hmm I
love Sasha Pieterse like I just have a
warm spot in my heart for her and I'm so
happy for her me too this is really cute
it's just so funny how like it wasn't
too long ago that all these actors were
playing high school kids so you think
that they're so young like they were you
know 18 a little while ago but they're
actually all like almost in their
thirties right well she's 24 oh so she
might have been more appropriately cast
than some of the other people right look
train Belisario methinks is well she has
like six year old energy she is a mature
vibe yeah she's mature are you gonna
look up how old she is yeah yeah Maran
Belisario is 34 Wow Sasha Pieterse is 24
Ashley Benson is 30 Shay Mitchell 33
Lucy Hale is 30 all right so I was me
and Janel Parrish is 30 so I was making
the argument for everyone I didn't
realize that extremist girls so much
younger
yeah I feel that well some good news
cement over Mazel Tov Mazda builds a
mint oh yeah
oh just like sounds like you know the
words it's just like yeah nein nein nein
nein nein if we just do like you got it
yeah it's really so sure you can know
the words to any song it's just like
it's just like doing watermelon yeah
like or youth they say if you like mouth
the alphabet you look like you know the
lyrics to a song so let's do
[Music]
nagi lebesgue he knows good yeah I think
that looks good okay next up in some
relatable news Cee Lo Green hopes to
come out of quarantine 30 to 40 pounds
lighter weight what silver eat is so
random
he's so random and he's hoping to come
out of lockdown in better shape quote I
definitely try to be mindful of what I
eat especially with the support of my
fiance Shanny in a perfect world when I
come out of quarantine I would like to
be 30 to 40 pounds lighter heed the
voice judge says that he's exercising at
home fortunately for us we live on a
Georgia ranch shut is about 10 acres so
he can go out and walk a mile and still
be in the confines of the house the
first thing I wanted to do when I got
money was to get a ranch speaking our
language speaking our language I love
Cee Lo Green
me too he is such an interesting career
um cuz he was like kind of randomly cast
on the voice like because nobody really
knows his name they knew him from Gnarls
Barkley and that song crazy which is
like honestly one of the most perfectly
written songs of all time and then he
came out with fu [ __ ] you yeah and that
was also like a total cultural reset but
they were like 10 years apart and then
he went on the voice and then
mysteriously disappeared and
had such an odd career in my mind but
he's like a cutie he's such a cutie and
he's trying to use this time to get into
shape which is what I thought I was
doing and I put in like two to three
really good retweets and I gained weight
so Zig when I just go back to how I was
doing before when I when I thought I was
gaining weight and I was actually saying
the same
maybe you're gaining muscle maybe from
appellate awning but also maybe like I'm
just gaining the weight like maybe was a
delayed weight gain you know my Patti's
trying to [ __ ] me
another weird thing Cee Lo Green did in
his career that's memorable as there was
a viral video of him sitting in a
recording studio using an Android member
and all those androids were blowing up
on the ends and one of them blowed blew
up in his hand and it's the craziest
video and then I heard it was fake oh I
never heard that part but I remember
that video yeah it's a black and white
like security footage from the recording
studio honestly if you google Cee Lo
Green it's so funny Google like iPhone
and no Android thing Cee Lo Green on
YouTube it's so funny
damn well I'm glad he's doing well in
the queue jealous of that farm tremon
life I know I need a ranch in Georgia
like that's it that is it okay are you
ready for our fifth and final story so
soon yeah I guess because it's a little
mmm nope it's a little book news oh you
mean a little not how one reads could
die from pee I look like I'm praying
like very devout like I'm Brad like you
just scan the whole page oh yeah that's
true have you have you ever seen those
like professional speed readers know if
we have you had in those videos are
crazy they take like huge stacks of
papers like as big as you and they take
the paper note how do we know for
they're reading it
you know I saw one on the news once they
were reading like um some bill was
passed and they were like doing it was
like such a dumb segment was obviously
like the news was really dry that day
and they got a speed reader to come like
read the whole legislation we need to do
[ __ ] like that
[Laughter]
yeah we're so desperate we're so
desperate okay just wanna have someone
come on the toast and like wax my upper
lip on camera oh my god I just I would
love that
speaking of people who could come on the
toast is thel around no he's with his fa
th ER hate to see it rats okay it's in
the founding story a little book news
[Music]
The Hunger Games prequel sells 500,000
copies in its debut Suzanne Collins his
new book The Ballad of sombart sand
snakes released last Tuesday reintroduce
his readers to the world of Pan Am and
the I mean that's how they say it right
Pan Am Pam hmmm
Pan Am yeah like damn its Pan Am and the
villainous tyrant president Coriolanus
Coriolanus
Coriolanus snow presents no Cornelius no
Coriolanus empirical decade after the
only serious head apparently and eight
videos were clearly rather ready for
more the new Suzanne Collins book sold
more than 500,000 copies last week even
as many of the country's book stores
were closed or offering limited service
because of the corona virus pandemic the
total includes print ebooks and audio
books according to the publisher
Scholastic I mean honestly the queue has
been I really think really great for the
book community including redheads and I
do think that this is just like an
interesting factoid that like a whole
new generation of hunger games like is
well on its way to becoming like the
first one yeah and I think like back in
the day maybe selling 500,000 books like
wasn't so
like it was like the top books did that
but given the fact that we've just
evolved so much like I don't know how
much you used to but like now I feel
like really good books sell like a
hundred to five hundred thousand books
like it's just not what I use due to the
fact that like in pre-order they're
almost at a million is crazy ya know the
book came out it's not just pretty low
okay um on Tuesday I think yeah I would
love how much does a book cost it
depends if you're your Kindle or
hardcover or paperback how much is a
Kindle Kindle is about like eleven
twelve dollars but I'm sure hers is and
then a hard covers like thirty dollars
so what's the middle one our eyes say
like eighteen are you trying to figure
out how much money she made that's nine
million dollars that's crazy that's
really good for her
yeah but also Kindles and ebooks like if
there's really no cost of production
versus a book you know you have to think
about those things
that's very true that's very very true
no cost of goods no cost of goods
speaking of I'm wearing this really cute
um fan merch for the redheads it's not
like a fish Oh
worse yet I wore mine yesterday right is
the same company it's the same company
yeah um a toaster like that's so cute
it's called bro denim they're toasters
they're so nice and I just I love this
sweatshirt and I love the redheads I
need to start our book student these
books that I'm reading I've never read a
book slower in my whole life it is 500
pages but still like I literally read
like 4 percent a day that's not how I
read but I think I use it 500 pages on
Kindle is Kindle pages the same as human
pages no it's five hundred and something
pages of book on Kindle it's like
thousands of tap throws comes wandering
that
I measure by book pages should we dive
into the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills recap which was on last night
there was no banner from pearl tonight
before so I like forgot about cable TV
it was so weird
mm-hmm this episode it was good we
picked up everyone met at Kyle's and
went to Santa Barbara Kyle is just being
so weird like about everything like I
thought it was like she was finally
gonna calm down when she invited your
/ before they left his hanna-barbera
just so I clear the air basically she
skewing she invited to read over just to
like rehash it again and like she was
like she was just what it's like say her
feelings and then be like let's just
sweep it under the rug and then like
when Tori would respond she was like so
taken aback it's like you just embedded
her over to sweep it onto the rug but
let you get your side out yeah in this
episode she was reminding me weirdly of
Lisa Vanderpump just the way she was
like engaging with the group like saying
sarcastic mean things I was just like is
this just maybe you know when you're on
the show for this long you become that
way or like she's filling the void of
Lisa Vanderpump I don't know yeah she
was also really reminding me looks-wise
I'm like early seasons Kyle because she
blew out her bangs and so they were a
little volumized up front and she really
looked like season 1 season 2 Kyle
Richards and I was having major
flashbacks Oh interesting okay let's
talk about the big fight between Denise
and the women about the children and
like I went on Twitter afterwards and I
agree like for the first time ever like
I agree with like the popular opinion on
Twitter so I don't know if that makes my
opinion popular or unpopular but I felt
like I was completely on Denise's side
no see I wasn't honestly it depends
there were so many parts of the fight
like I thought Lisa was really coming
for Denise in so many weird ways not
only weird because they're such close
friends but just like any like Lisa was
just being off but at the same time like
Denise did make it a bigger deal and the
women ran with it but like she was the
one who made it a big deal I'm like
Erika apologize and she still was going
on and on about it so I thought that the
women were being definitely a little
harsh but Denise like kind of invited it
yeah well I think it really bothered her
and like she it wasn't something where I
was like okay this bothers me but
whatever it's over it's like I want to
make sure that this never happens again
and then for the women to call her like
a hypocrite because of what she does in
her adult life when there's children or
him then Erika making that asinine
comment about um the 14 year old
probably having threesomes was just it
was not right oh so Lisa Rinna was so
uninvolved in this like she wasn't even
talking in the conversation she wasn't
even one of the people Denise told us to
and she's one of Denise's closest
friends like
why was she like so excited to join the
pylon and I just bothering me
I thought Denise handled herself so well
I do think there is a complete like line
in the sand when it comes to children
and whether you agree with Denise or not
like we're not gonna talk about
threesomes in front of her children okay
like good to know I'm sorry that we even
put you in that position in the first
place oh and her kids friends were there
and what if they are telling her parents
like it's just a huge [ __ ] pit for
her and I think she had a pity she
shared it with the group yeah but like
honestly I I see the side of the women
who are like don't invite us to your
like she should know better like she's
hanging out with this women she has been
hanging out with these women for at
least a year like things always take a
turn when they drink and they talk about
like crazy things and it's like to me
she should have known better than to
even have the kids and their friends or
to literally see them right next to the
adults and at the end of the day like
these women show up to film and this is
their job and they need to be funny and
they need to be outlandish and it's like
it's just like don't invite me somewhere
where I'm gonna be restricted like I get
that and it does seem odd coming from
Denise given how open she's been on TV
that her kids could possibly see about
the hookers about the happy endings and
now it's like now you want to tell us -
calm down like I totally get why it
feels hypocritical okay I see what
you're saying about they have to be able
to like film and be themselves but they
go to like swanky events all the time
where it's like we can't do this here
there's always something where it's like
okay we can't fight here you want to
come to my daughter's launch event like
you can't flip out so when there's a two
kids table next door just the adults you
can be like fun and funny and just not
have like inappropriate conversations
and I think that for Denise she clearly
doesn't let her kids watch the show and
there's a difference between doing
something on TV or over hearing it in
your own house as a child that is a very
interesting parallel to draw like all
the women coming at sudden for even
thinking of you know having a bitch-fit
anxiety kind of the children much right
but Lisa Rinna has apparently no qualms
about the women saying you know dirty
things in front of Denise Richards kids
that's actually very good this is why I
don't like to fight with you like that
was a fabulous parallel wow thank you so
much I don't realize that you made such
a good point if you like glaze right
over it
you're just full of comments tonight um
I I also think that Denise just handled
herself really well and maybe if she
hadn't I wouldn't have taken her side
but I thought she was so calm and
collected I also like really love that
Dury silently has her back you know I
just love to read I just love to read
like even when they were talking about
her before she got there to read leg
refused to participate and that's just a
good friend and Lisa Rinna just lives
for it and her asking like what's it
like to film a threesome and all of
these crazy questions at this awful
awful dinner and it's like we went to
dinner Tanisha's house and we couldn't
not like be so crazy and talk but we're
here adults only trip Santa Barbara
let's go wild and we can't even like
have an interesting conversation I was
really disappointed honestly that
Garcelle didn't come because I already
felt like she was a little bit behind
and getting involved with the girls in
the drama like it hasn't been that many
episodes but Suns had her fair share of
punches and Garcelle I just felt like
this really set her back even more and I
would have loved for her to be there
yeah especially because it seems like
Denise and Garcelle are on the same page
about just life and also I'm starting to
feel like Garcelle is actually too busy
to be doing this show like the women
always talk about their projects and
they're so busy and we're stressed and
we're tired and you know like everyone
tries to compete with each other about
how busy they are but I think our cell
is officially too busy if you can't make
the cash trip in Santa Barbara which is
literally like a drive away it's not
even flight yeah it's one of the lower
and lifts of being a real housewife of
Beverly Hills I agree which was really
upsetting because I would have wanted
her to be there um I just found the
whole episode to be so strange because
I've been watching this franchise from
the beginning and I've always pretty
much felt like Kyle was really like the
center you know she wasn't always like
so crazy she wasn't starting fighting
she for the most part took the side of
the person that she thought was right
and I just feel like everything that
comes out of her mouth the season is so
unreasonable and so illogical and I just
cannot like get on board with any of it
yeah I agree
I interesting to like go back and watch
old seasons like through the lens of
like how she always been this way but
there's always been a bigger manipulator
in the group
and you know Kyle was always like really
close with Lisa Vanderpump and I think
maybe Lisa Vanderpump took a lot of the
shouldering of people calling her a
villain not that - Kyle's a villain but
she is behaving differently the season I
feel like it the way that I see it is
just like she feels like now this is her
show like she broke up a friendship of
hers to like liberate these women from
Lisa Vanderpump and and now I want
everyone to behave the way I see fit
yeah I was really disappointed in her
reaction and just interactions this
episode with Erica because she owes
Erica a major apology for saying
something so mean to Erica in her own
[ __ ] house and not only did she not
apologize she stood her ground and then
continued to make fun of Erica's outfits
the entire episode yeah I I do think she
owes her an apology and also that's
another point where as like Erica I just
like you know I love her I just like
really wasn't um on her side this
episode because I feel like when it
comes to being in her house there are so
many rules you can't like you know the
way you with Tom they're like you just
have to act a certain way and so for her
to like not understand that Denise might
have that same sort of boundary in her
house with her kids like just didn't
ring like totally well I'm in it I'm an
Erica sympathizer and I feel like she
understood that Denise was upset and she
apologized and I feel like in her mind
like that should have been enough and
the fact that Denise kept bringing up
that's what upset her she didn't really
take any issue with didn't what house
niece was feeling but it's like wait
what's a point in apologizing if we're
not gonna move on yeah I agree with that
I also think Erica like really does not
do well when she feels like she's being
judged for being like primis anything
like so when it's a threesome and it's
like everyone's talking about her
threesome like she really does not like
that like she's happy to talk about it
when she brings it up and like she wants
to share with the group but now when it
gets like weaponized against her is a
very similar feeling when the whole like
stressed or EPK thing when she's like
that's how it started that treat was
like accusing her not wearing under
around purpose and like Erica just does
not stand for that which I love and
that's why we were just sucked her yeah
I thought it was really an interesting
episode and the tides are turning and I
want to go to that house in San I just
want to go to Santa Barbara that house
was beautiful except a woman who was in
charge of like introducing them to the
house who obviously was living in a pre
cobain America because she was hugging
all these random strangers and sudden
was like no I don't hug that was so
funny and so weird and probably the best
part of the episode yeah I'm feeling
Sutton more and more me know she said
that like she's not a hugger I was like
I can fully relate thanks very much
and she was bringing she was making good
points in the group setting also so she
wasn't bothering me and I'm she's making
strides
yes she's found a balance of being
relevant but not annoying yeah well
she's kind of just staying out of the
fray she's gonna have to get her hands
dirty soon but right now I think she's
in a good good like she's on the bench
but she's doing like good cheering so
was Garcelle Garcelle is gonna have to
you know pull up her bootstraps and get
to work well GAR cells not even on the
bench like she's not even at the game in
the sand right she's in Nashville yeah
she's in the car it's um it's
frustrating because I really like her I
need more I need more too but well I'm
hoping that in a lot of ways being on
this season will affect her career in a
positive way and they'll give her
another season and she'll be able to
work less because this show is so much a
part of like her brand now hoping here's
hoping but you know what it's like I was
thinking about it I know some of the
shows are like filming themselves in
quarantine but there's gonna be like a
big lull after you know when all those
shows that should be filming right now
would be airing like in a year you know
when are we gonna get a next season of
Beverly Hills even know I have no idea
that's a great point so something to
think about
we have Real Housewives of New York
tonight which I'm excited about and
that's it that's all she wrote make sure
to go to shop morning toast calm after
1:00 p.m. Eastern Time because we just
launched our new face masks there are
four different options and they're
available completely unlimited stock
until Sunday this week so make sure to
get them tell your mom tell your brother
you got four days get whatever you need
um
sure to order my comedy special while
you're just like buying things it's
available for pre-order on iTunes
Claudia ASHRAE just graced Queen um you
could tap the link in my bio on girl
with no job thank you so much for the
support and all the reviews and the
ratings I really appreciate it I love
you guys if you're looking to take some
fabulous photos this weekend make sure
to go to Jackie O flow comm by Jackie's
new pack of presets they are fabulous
like I keep selling well I keep telling
Jackie Mikey ah to give this person free
presets like it's just so fabulous and
you really just need it so Jackie O Flo
comm check it out thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast of
millennium morning chivalry live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so be watching that shows us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that Spotify
iTunes stitcher publicly public video
IRA their cast box all the places
whoever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows and leave a 5 star
review about a beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys very much
we'll be up a great and we'll see you
tomorrow for Friday bye